[Música]
bom eu vou contar uma história divertida
pra vocês
tudo começa no final da década de 70 dos
jovens conhecem se apaixonam e decidem
se casar
dois anos depois nasceu o menino o lugar
itacolomi na ilha do governador um
bairro criado sobre uma aldeia indígena
e o seu nome da economia era em
homenagem a um grande líder indígena o
caboclo itacolomi morando em uma casa de
chão batido uma pequena cozinha um
quarto e banheiro ao completar dois anos
de idade seus pais se separam e por obra
do destino o seu pai ficar rico na
loteria esportiva mas decidi não deixar
nada para a mãe do seu filho com os
problemas e as adversidade batendo à sua
porta
mas a sua mãe muito guerreira além de
manicure
ela também trabalha como faxineira na
casa de conhecidos
isso para obter o mínimo necessário para
conseguir pagar uma creche e se
alimentarem por conta do projeto de
expansão do aeroporto internacional aqui
do rio de janeiro o bairro foi
desapropriado e as famílias migraram
para embalar e em duque de caxias e
tubiacanga uma pequena colônia de
pescadores na ilha do governador
ao completar cinco anos de idade o
menino a sua mãe e agora um padrasto se
mudam eo menino então é criado em uma
comunidade também na ilha do governador
assim como atualmente para se estudar em
uma escola particular de ensino de
qualidade
a família precisa ter uma excelente
condição financeira e isso não foi
diferente para a família do menino e aos
sete
ele ingressa na escola municipal até
concluir o ensino fundamental
porém aos 12 anos de idade
ele começa a trabalhar informalmente por
já demonstrar um grande interesse com a
tecnologia
já adolescente e trabalhando de forma
formalmente né
sem apoio incentivo e nenhuma cobrança
por parte da sua família
o menino então é reprovado três vezes no
ensino médio
quase que ele desiste de estudar mas ele
não parou
ele ingressou no supletivo por conta
própria e desejou concluir todo o ensino
médio até ingressar na universidade de
tecnologia mas junto disso os problemas
familiares se agravaram em um dia em uma
discussão o jovem então decidiu sair de
casa e prometeu nunca mais voltar
dois anos e meio se passaram na
universidade o trabalho formal exigindo
muito do rapaz que faz com que ele
abandone o seu curso ele se torna a
primeira vez um do pote do pote ao
famoso cair fora
ele é associado à toda pessoa que entra
no curso e não conclui isso repetiu mais
uma vez para o rapaz porém muito
obstinado e com o propósito de ter
sucesso para ajudar as pessoas de
minoria
ele então passa por algumas empresas até
que o desemprego chega pra ele
já morando de favor na casa de uma tia o
rapaz então precisa se reinventar e ele
decide voltar a atender todos aqueles
seus antigos clientes em suas
residências
junto disso para complementar a sua
renda ele se torna jardineiro foi um
bálsamo para a vida dele foi um grande
aprendizado
passado alguns anos já com cinco anos
casado com muitos sonhos uma crise se
aproxima
e junto dela vem a separação e novamente
o desemprego
o rapaz então decidi sair da casa
deixando tudo para sua esposa e ele
volta a morar naquela favela que ele foi
criado com o amigo dele é foram nove
meses desempregado separado
muitos dias em muitos meses sem ter até
o que comer
o rapaz então com muita luta procurando
emprego em todos os lugares que era
possível em lojas de informática portais
de emprego anúncios e nada até que um
dia ele visitando uma grande amiga ao
sair de sua casa ele avista sobrinha
dessa amiga seus olhares se cruzam com
certeza afinidade estava no ar até que
em uma rápida pesquisa ela descobre o
nome do rapaz chegou adiciona no antigo
orkut
provavelmente alguns aqui lembram do
orkut né então namoro começa e o
universo de forma positiva responde ao
casal dando a oportunidade de emprego
para o rapaz ele muito feliz ele sai
correndo da lan house para ir até a sua
casa separar sua roupa e dinheiro para
entrevista do dia seguinte
mas ao chegar em casa ele se depara com
70 centavos em sua carteira
sim setenta centavos bom
o jeito era ligar para a sua mãe para
pedir ajuda
ele já não se viam há mais de cinco anos
e se falava muito pouco e como é de se
imaginar a mãe não pôde ajudar o rapaz
ele muito frustrado muito triste
ele aguardou o seu amigo chegar de noite
à sua casa e contou tudo que ocorreu no
dia eu amigo muito sensibilizado o ajuda
com o único dinheiro em sua carteira
vinte reais feito entrevista emprego
três meses se passam na empresa e um
jovem casal decide então se juntar e se
casar
eles vão para um apartamento alugado e
junto deles vão mais dois meninos um
pequenininho de dois anos e um outro de
7 anos
esses meninos eram os filhos dessa jovem
que acabaram se tornando também filho do
rapaz felicidade amil tudo certo até que
em um ano o desemprego bate novamente à
sua porta e ele precisa se reinventar
novamente mas não só ele também a sua
esposa e agora pois é em um dia
desesperado o jovem leandro os
classificados do jornal para procurar
emprego até que ele vê uma notícia
ele lê excursão para paraguai minas são
paulo
friburgo bom essa era a hora
eles então decidem se juntar a entregar
tudo aquilo que tinham e começa uma
longa jornada para comprar roupas tênis
eletrônicos para começar a render tudo
que era possível revender eles fizeram
menos drogas
tudo começa a dar certo uma duas três
barraquinhas em feiras livres as contas
começando a se estabilizar as despesas
começando a se amenizar até que a sua
esposa grávida
pois é não foi um transtorno
todos podem ter imaginado que seria mas
não foi esse era a realização de um
desejo um sonho do rapaz de se tornar
pai novamente
mas como suprir a necessidade de três
crianças no brasil sem o emprego formal
complicado né pois é
a criança nasce em um lindo menino mas o
menino pra completar a família
três meninos quase um time de futebol ou
uma roda de capoeira
o menino nas 11 dias internado na uti
com um grave problema pulmonar
até que os seus pais decidem botar o
nome do menino de miguel por conta de
são miguel arcanjo
eles tinham a certeza absoluta que essa
criança viveria o mundo para trazer luz
à prosperidade muita felicidade para a
sua família
e acreditem foi isso após três meses do
nascimento do menino
o jovem então recebe uma proposta de
emprego em uma empresa sólida com a
administração justa e meritocrática
pronto feito emprego
passaram se dez meses na empresa até que
o rapaz é surpreendido e assume a
gerência nacional da empresa ficando sob
a sua gestão 18 estados no país
uma maravilha as viagens de negócios de
trabalho proporcionando uma abertura de
visão para negócios nunca antes
percebida até que ele junto de dois
amigos se juntam e decidem fundar uma
aceleradora de negócios sustentáveis com
foco em meio ambiente sustentabilidade e
economia colaborativa
isso para que todo mundo pudesse ganhar
e crescer de forma justa e igualitária
foi ótimo em uma outra viagem de
trabalho ele tem a oportunidade de
conhecer o empreendedor belga
sim os dois juntos conversando
encontraram sinergia propósito e
complementariedade também aos negócios
decidi então os dois juntos fundaram em
uma startup em luxemburgo na europa
para quem não conhece luxamburgo é um
estado soberano na europa que faz divisa
com a frança bélgica e alemanha
tudo caminhando perfeitamente em um ano
e oito meses
a empresa recebe um aporte financeiro
sendo incubada no vale do silício na
califórnia um dos maiores ecossistemas
de empreendedorismo do planeta
mas o que o rapaz fez ele decidiu sair
da empresa ele decidiu vender a sua
parte
ele acreditava que era possível investir
no brasil e lutar pela população e ele o
fez
ele voltou a conversar com os seus
outros dois sócios até
e eles três juntos viram a idéia de
colocar em prática dois outros novos
negócios que ele já pensava em abrir
foram lá e fizeram eles fundarem uma
indústria de impressora 3d genuinamente
nacional e uma startup de gestão de
resíduos foi um sucesso
em um ano a indústria de impressora 3d
25% delas foi vendida para investidores
e a startup de gestão de resíduos em
apenas três meses de fundação recebeu um
importante prêmio nacional e foi
incubada no maior programa de formação
de empreendedores do brasil
tudo caminhando perfeitamente dois anos
na empresa que ele trabalhava aquela lá
que ele teve a oportunidade quando seu
filho nasceu ele é surpreendido
novamente
a empresa adquirida por um grande grupo
suíço tornando se então uma grande
multinacional ea segunda maior do mundo
em seu segmento
os anos se passaram e com cinco anos de
multinacional
o rapaz então decide se desligar da
empresa seus negócios já estavam
começando a caminhar novos negócios
estavam surgindo e ele tinha o propósito
de aplicar tudo aquilo que ele aprendeu
no exame mas para a sociedade para as
pessoas que não tinham acesso e nem
apoio ele o fez em dois anos com muito
suor muita luta e pouco dinheiro quase
nada
o rapaz então identifica uma escassez de
oportunidade e fomento ao
empreendedorismo em regiões periféricas
no rio de janeiro mas associado a isso
ele também conseguiu identificar uma
abundância de capital humano e
intelectual
nestas mesmas regiões foi aí então que
ele teve uma idéia
ele anota no papel faz um plano de
negócio eleva para dois amigos
investidores
foi lindo eles adoraram a idéia apoiaram
e apoio
estarão os dois se tornaram seus sócios
investidores no negócio
nasce então o primeiro qual o working e
rubi de inovação e empreendedorismo para
regiões periféricas do brasil
esse rapaz sou eu e com nove meses de
empresa de forma social
nós formamos mais de 200 pessoas
apoiamos e patrocinamos uma equipe de
jovens cyber atletas de região
periférica do rio de janeiro
possuímos mais de 20 clientes fixos na
empresa
todos eles empreendedores de região
periférica do rio
fundamos a primeira incubadora de
startup da baixada fluminense aqui no
rio de janeiro
eu estou devolvendo para o universo em
forma de agradecimento a tudo aquilo que
eu conquistei a minha esposa
os nossos três filhos os amigos que
acreditaram em mim e me apoiaram assim
como eu acredito na periferia do rio de
janeiro e de todo o brasil
se eu sair da favela se eu criei
se eu conquistei qualquer um é capaz
disso
eu acredito que é possível criar um
oásis no meio do deserto empreendedor
acredita em obrigado
[Aplausos]